So what about the more standard method?
The more standard method is
actually just like light striping.
So you recognize this figure, this is
the light stripes where we project
out the stripes,
look at them from a camera, and
then we see that the stripes bend
depending upon the depth of the object.
So, as we said before,
you're still just doing stereo, okay?
Except instead of two cameras, you're
actually doing projection of one and
coming out the other.
But the thing that I want to remind you
about stereo is if you know the relative
geometry of the cameras, you know how
they're, they're aligned and their,
their offsets et cetera, right, their
extrinsics and their intrinsics, right.
Then for any given location in one
image, there is an epipolar line,
remember, in the other
image along which to look.
Now, this is also true for
the projection method, right?
So if I project a point out, right,
at some location in one image,
then depending upon the depth of
the scene in my other image, yes,
I'm over here, Meg, in the other image,
where that will, point will be,
will be along an epipolar line.
And how far along the line it is
is a function of the depth, so
I only have to search in along
a line if I know the calibration.
Well, In my Kinect system,
of course I know the calibration between
the projector and the camera,
but instead of projecting lines,
what we're going to do is we're
going to project out a speckle pattern.
So instead of a regular projector,
we're using a Kinect.
Instead of line stripes,
we're spraying out a pattern of,
they call them pseudo-random
speckles because it's important that
the pattern be a little different
everywhere so that I can do a, ready?
Normalized correlation, all right.
Instead of using a camera, I use my
Kinect, because the Kinect actually,
if you take a look at it, has a little
projector in it and a camera.
And the relationship
between those are known.
And then what the camera sees
is a speckle pattern, but
where the dots are offset
as a function of the depth.
So that's shown here.
So here's a picture so it's looking
flat, this is from one perspective.
It's actually sort of faked in how it's
doing it, but don't worry about it.
If it was just a flat wall, but if I
change the depth, so I put a little book
on this stand, right, you see that's
the difference between the depth, right?
So on the left one I'm just projecting
it on a flat wall and looking at it, and
on the right, that's the offset
that comes from the book, right?
And, and by the way, what is this
little pattern, this little thing here?
That's a shadow, right, because
the thing is offset a little bit, and
I'm projecting here,
there's a little area right here that I
can see with the camera that
can't be seen by the projector.
That's what the black pattern is.
In this particular case, the projection
is coming from this side, and
the camera is coming from that side.
All right.